the other thing that freaks me out about
the internet is how
how gullible it makes you and it makes
me anything I read on the internet I
believe right me Billy eilish explains
her complicated relationship with the
internet who's the internet during her
appearance on the Conan O'Brien needs a
friend podcast the singer details
growing up in cyberspace for me it was
like a big part of my and not my
childhood I wasn't like an iPad baby
thank God I really had such a childhood
and I was doing stuff all the time and
it was like computers and like games on
computers but barely you know and then
it was like we were doing stuff and then
when I became you know a preteen there
was iPhones and then there was you know
I got a little older and there was all
of what has become but then being like a
pre-teen and a teenager on the internet
that those were my people of course
Billy became famous as a teen
[Music]
[Applause]
I never in a million years would have
thought this would happen and with the
fame came toxic social media attention
like a video came up I was with my
boyfriend the other day and we were
sitting there and this video came up and
it was like
like Billy eilish is a horrible person
and then it was like a very serious
video of why and the person seemed like
very you know like
in the in the right headspace and they
were saying all these things they were
convincing you
like jeez that's why the Grammy winners
now keeping her distance from it I've
deleted it all off my phone
um which is
such a huge deal for me you know there
will be a photo of me somewhere at the
gym and then I'll see paparazzi photos
of me there and that's what I was doing
and it says like Billy eilish in
Hollywood going to a studio to work on
her new album
and that's such a small lie but I'm like
why would you even need to lie about
that it just is very strange and then it
makes me like wow how much was a lie
that I was reading when I was looking at
the internet well it seems Billy's
enjoying her time away from the web
doing relaxing activities which is so
incredible and it was so amazing the 21
year old who still sometimes posts on
Instagram just shared these pics
horseback riding sunbathing taking a
drive and completing a puzzle
me from you I'm happier than ever
wish I could explain it better
I wish it wasn't true
thank you